if your teenager watching this and you
have some symptoms of an entrepreneur or
you kind of want to become an
entrepreneur but you don't know yet
I almost feel bad for you let me tell
you why because becoming an entrepreneur
is very similar to becoming an artist
and most kids who are artists they're
different so academia our school system
is not structured to really water this
artist and turn them into what they
could be I can only imagine how weird of
a kid Johnny Depp was to teacher in
sixth grade I can only imagine how
Picasso was seen in school or an
Einstein within the school the thing
with entrepreneurs this is why 99% of
your teachers in school are not
entrepreneurs and they've never been an
entrepreneur so how do they know to
speak your language so you are going to
feel a little weird you are going to
feel a little bit different and I simply
want to create this platform for you to
look at this video and share with your
other peers to say one you're not alone
and two it's going to be a little bit
weird and just bear with it it's going
to be okay
14 common common common mistakes I'll
give you today a lot of them I went
through myself and hopefully it'll give
you some value for you to be thinking
about that the future looks bright and
don't overthink it too much so let's get
right into it point number one here's
point number one life is not Disneyland
the happiest place on earth that is a
lie that's what you call a commercial
okay that's what gets people to want to
go to Disneyland for where for one day
we're at Disneyland and we think we're
at the happiest place on earth
that's called creative marketing that's
called fantastic marketing let me tell
you shocker here for you to know most of
your friends don't want to see you
succeed that's confusing most of the
people in school don't want to see you
kill it very few do I know this is very
weird
it's almost as if your friends are very
happy as long as you do a little bit
less than they do so if you get a B+
they're okay if they got an A if you are
dating a pretty girl it's okay as long
as they're dating a prettier girl but
they're not happy if you're doing better
than them so you got to know that part
and it's nothing wrong this doesn't mean
your friends are bad people it's just
how people are wired for the most part
and I know
a lot of comments people going to say I
don't think that's what it is my breast
best friend thinks the world of me and
and she loves me and he loves me
you can keep thinking like that my
life's not there Zinman you're going to
be shell-shocked very early on when you
go through the life number two don't
worry about breaking too many rules I'm
here to tell you I think too many
teenage entrepreneurs don't break the
rules enough times I didn't say law I
said rules break the rules you got to
break the rules more why because the
only way we figure out how to make
anything better is by breaking it down a
little bit and breaking the rules a
little bit to find out if we can do this
thing a little bit better than the way
it's been done all these years
don't worry about breaking the rules too
often people going to make you feel bad
and all this other stuff don't worry
about it break more rules not laws don't
come back and say Pat told me to break
the line never said law don't break
enough break more rules not lost with
rules number three is comparing yourself
too much to others you don't need to
compare yourself to other people you
know this person is that person did this
this person did this even as Zuckerberg
even a you know mosque or all these guys
let them inspire you but don't compare
yourself to other people here's why
there's no way in the world you can be
like them and there's no way in the
world they can be like you very simple
your unique their unique play to your
own unique abilities you don't need to
worry about comparing yourself to
everybody else not next point being too
concerned as a young entrepreneur about
somebody of sealing your ideas listen
don't worry if someone's going to steal
your ideas first of all you hoarding
your idea is not going to tell the world
anything anyways that the biggest
challenge you got to know about ideas is
99.999% of the world is going to do
nothing with your idea just notice
99.999% of the people are not going to
take your idea at all they're just not
going to take it because the entire game
is execution so I would much rather be a
little bit more comfortable about
sharing your idea with other people that
saying I'm not going to tell them about
if you keep it the world's definitely
not going to know about it if you talk
to somebody else they can possibly help
you turn that idea into a bigger idea
than it currently is today next this is
very powerful pay very close attention
what I'm telling you right now
don't let logic bully you let me say it
again
don't let logic bully you what is logic
age age bullies people let me elaborate
there will be a 42 year old teacher that
you have and you're this
fourteen-year-old kid and you got dreams
and you say one day I'm gonna be this
and one day I'm gonna be this and one
day I'm gonna be this and you get too
smart from that teacher that's all I
remember when I was your age and I used
to dream that life is going to be this
but it's not that's a logical thinker
they gave up at one point do not let
that logical person influence you don't
you keep dreaming I know the word logic
curve is not a word because the dreamer
versus a logical logical is not a word
I'm making other word don't let a person
that purely looks at everything through
the logical views bully a dreamer which
is you don't let him do it do not let
them do it and a lot of times its age
it's a 52 year old uncle who thinks he
knows everything but he's broke his
report card is a straight F stop taking
that uncle's advice he got an F the only
advice you need to take from that uncle
is the following advice what mistakes
did you make to get you to where you're
at right now if you truly want to help
me out mr. uncle it's tell me about the
mistakes on why you're still broke live
in an apartment complex tell me the
mistakes don't bully my dreams I have
dream and I want to give a shot you see
if I can go out and make my dreams
become a reality
you gave up you screwed up to me your
mistakes I wanted to listen to you with
your mistakes but I don't want you to
bully my drinks if you want to bully my
troops I don't even want to hear it I
don't want to hear any of it so don't
let age or logic bully you next team up
with the most driven in school not your
best friend a lot of times your best
friends are your best friends that
you'll like them but one of them is more
concerned about smoking pot and having
sex with his girlfriend 24/7 than doing
anything big with his life you can't do
anything with that guy if he doesn't
want to work so if some of your friends
are more worried about the cool points
they're going to get all this other
stuff but then there's that one cat
who's a nerd and nobody talks him but
he's a ridiculous coder you can make
friends with him okay there's another
guy that works 24/7 he sells baseball
calls on campus and he's always selling
something anyone makes fun of them
befriends bad guy because that guy can
help you sell your product he can be
your Steve Jobs
Goldfine
somebody the hardest-working people on
campus that are selling that a running
business is making money on the side
hustling on Instagram doing stuff on
snapchat befriend them get them together
not just your best friend complete
different strategy you got to take with
that next this sounds like a preachy
type of thing but listen take care your
health early avoid Burger King you know
McDonald's all that fast food so just
not necessary for you to go out to eat
that so some of you guys wonder why you
get a lot of acne is just eating a lot
of oily food you don't need to eat the
oil liquid ice I have acne a lot as a
kid
only food is not a way to go boy that
stuff take care of your health
very very early the moment I figured out
the whole oily thing I started working
out and taking care of my health
somewhat earlier more than some of my
peers did it benefited me start taking
care of your health or your next reading
crappy books you don't need to read
crappy books now let me tell what I
don't mind when I say crappy books if
you read books that are about
imagination and it takes you to some
places that makes you visualize things
that are just crazy and that's fine
that's that's that's cool to be reading
books like that I'm talking about books
that have no purpose that serve no
purpose to you read business books I'm
gonna make another video on top 10 books
teenage entrepreneurs need to read but
that'll be another episode that'll come
up stay tuned for that but but for now
just stop avoid reading crappy books
next one learn the difference between
ass-kissing and networking there's a big
difference some students want to
kiss-ass to their teachers right we used
to call them everybody sit MPA or
teacher's pet and all this other things
that they say don't be an ass kisser be
a great network let me tell you who to
network with here's a perfect thing to
be thinking about go to your principal
ask around
which one of the teachers in your school
at one point was a professional athlete
go ask them what it takes to be a
professional athlete to find that any
teacher principal counselor on campus
who used to run a successful business
before who sold it now their way of
giving back to public they want to
become teachers different that teacher
take that teacher out to lunch take that
teacher I said when can they spend an
hour with me after school going to
network with that person by the way you
can find out who those teachers are in
every school you go to
I promise you right now if you're
watching this if I were to ask you who's
the richest teacher on campus I
guarantee you everybody typically knows
who the richest teacher on campus
everyone knows that you know why because
everybody talks about it and by the way
FYI majority the teachers don't like
that teacher because that teacher has
money and they did it backwards they
first want to make their money then they
became teachers a lot of these teachers
became teachers right after school and
some of them are not doing too well
money West goes on they don't make a lot
of money I admire teachers don't get me
wrong
futures impact on my life tremendously
but if you want to network network with
the guy that knows all the right people
next stop trying to be cool when you're
young I was dying to be cool when I was
12 13 14 years old you know I had just
come to America I had a terrible accent
I didn't even know how to pronounce
certain words you're going to spend way
too much time trying to be cool and
trying to make everybody else happy
don't fall for it just realize this is
you this is how you are maximize what
you got
don't try to get coupons from everybody
else next point avoid putting yourself
in dumb situations let me just simplify
it for you this is this is not something
that's complicated I remember a few
occasions of my life once I got arrested
in Hollywood at one o'clock in the
morning I got arrested cops came
handcuffed the whole nine it could have
been worse but it didn't we were good we
left everything was fine we didn't get
arrested or anything that now but they
handcuffed us helicopters chasing us all
this stuff of 16 years I just bought a
new car another one was a big fight that
took place and I was hanging out with
the peers and this fight was a very big
fight cops came they were about to
arrest me the other guys that were with
us I was about to get arrested there
were a few people that night that got
felonies and I was able to after
conversations with the cops they were
able to let me go let me tell you why
this is so critical for you to pay
attention to if I would have gotten that
felony at a young age let's just say
that would have happened I woulda never
gone into the army if I would have never
gone into the army for three years I
would have learned the discipline if I
wouldn't have gone to learn the
discipline in the army and gotten out
and wanted to be this bodybuilder I
would have never met a girl named Jean
Pierre if I would have never met a girl
named Jean veer I wouldn't
worked on Morgan Stanley Dean Witter and
if I would have gone a misdemeanor or a
felony Morgan Stanley Dean Witter would
have never hired me you know why because
you can't go into the securities
industry with a felony for ten years so
I would have never gone into the
financial industry this entire story of
PVD is a different story this entire
story of Patrick made David value Tim
and PHP is a complete different story
so don't put yourself in dumb situations
what are some of the dumb situations
condoms drugs pot alcohol DUI pregnancy
avoid some of those situations because
they can be a major setback to a lot of
people next one here don't make sex your
god I know when you're 13 years old
you're 14 years old boys especially all
you think about is sex sex sex
will I ever hacks have sex let me make a
prediction to you the chances of you
having sex is very high and not only
sick you don't have a lot of sex in your
life okay lots of it I promise you no
one is 42 years old sitting there saying
oh my gosh I didn't have enough you're
going to be fine don't but the more
patient you the more attention you give
to that the more your mind is going to
places instead of trying to come up with
ideas on these other thoughts your mind
is being consumed by thoughts that
really are not going to do anything for
you and not by battle I understand the
hormonal thing and at that age wind
breezes this way you're excited you see
somebody every other day we fall in love
with somebody new one days Vivica Fox
one day it's like you know rachel
mcadams another day is jennifer dis and
other days the Jessica Biel Netta dates
this don't worry you're going to get
plenty of this plenty of this just don't
make sex your gut just trust me on this
you'll find out what I mean by this ten
years from now just trust me on this
okay next one next one are we got that
next one feeling like you don't matter
let me explain sometimes depending on
the family you're raised in you may be
raised in a family where your parents
are going through a divorce or there's a
lot of hate screaming shouting fighting
arguing and there are a lot of things
that your mom and that are going through
that you will never know about let me
tell you that
so sometimes parents no one's perfect
a mom or a dad is going to
without their frustration on their kids
it's just kind of what happens because
you're around the most especially if you
raised in a divorced family sometimes
they're going to put their anger their
frustration their regrets their own
stuff they don't mean it better you just
happen to be there they say those types
of things to you and these things become
scars scars scars and and the biggest
challenge with this is is that you start
believing it you've got to be you've got
to be I mean you got common sense
because anything after six years old
seven years old eight years or you start
developing some common sense you got
common sense to know that they don't
really fully mean it they're in pain
there are not a lot of pain this doesn't
mean it's not going to hurt this doesn't
mean it's not going to stick this
doesn't you're going to forget about it
but it doesn't mean it's the truth so
they say something works you that you'll
never amount to anything you'll never do
this you'll never do that you'll never
do that you'll never do this to me that
can actually toughen you up for you to
say you know what this is this is my
opportunity to prove that I can be
somebody and not only that for you to
really dig in dig deep and realize that
everybody else out there like imagine
the kid who invented cannon at one point
he was eight years old with a dream what
if he gave up imagine Steve Jobs when he
was 10 years old then his mom gave him
up for adoption for somebody else when
he was a young kid
now what if this kid gives up on Apple
imagine if Wozniak who was a kid a geek
one time playing with video games and
breaking down every single thing that he
had and putting him back what if he gave
up because somebody told him something
what if Zuckerberg gave up
what if mosque gave up what if Travis
gave up what if all these guys gave up
when they were all these guys were kids
at one point Brock Obama was a former
president we had I won't point it was
six years old and the kid that people
laughed at Donald Trump's the current
president at one point it was ten years
old and people laughed that up so just
the same way they go through it the same
way you got to realize is that one day
you're going to be 52 years old and you
have the ability to impact everybody
around the world don't let some of those
words of people and pain impact you of
your decision to go out and do something
big with your life stay patient good
things are going to be around the corner
for you don't buy into their challenges
that they're facing and last but not
least last but not least the one I'll
give you your last but not least is
studying the right kind
let me tell you what I mean by studying
the right content there's a lot of
people on internet right now telling you
what to do and what not to do and you'll
have to learn how to dice a decipher
between the right content and the right
the wrong content but I'm here to tell
you this I suggest you go backwards and
go through every single value came an
episode that we have on YouTube right
now one of the things that's happening
is value team has become a phenomenon
amongst teenage entrepreneurs obviously
CEOs of multi multi-billion dollar
companies are following item in the CEO
of a sprin theater they retweeted one of
the episodes that we had we're getting
celebrities and other a file on dates
we're getting billionaires out or not
following this but there's also very big
file on a teenage entrepreneurs on value
team I wish when I was 13 years old
there was a channel like value came in
for me to watch the episode study the
right content there's a lot of good
content out there as well but study the
right content based on people who are
running businesses not based on people
who are telling you things that they
picked up from a book always find out
how the person that's teaching you the
content online is has made their money
this is what I call a trifecta
entrepreneur somebody that has theories
somebody that has experience and
somebody that's applying their theories
and their experience and they're winning
now as in the world of entrepreneurship
so make sure you getting that content so
my challenge to you would be watch the
value statement content go back to back
to back to back with these episodes and
you'll be amazed two weeks three weeks
four weeks we get hundreds of messages
from teenage entrepreneurs from around
the world that say last month I made
$16,000 this month I made $8,000 this
week I made $4,000 last month I made
$28,000 I had a 17 year old kid that
came to Houston to visit me he's still
in high school he made fifty seven
thousand dollars last month as a teenage
entrepreneur and if you would have seen
him he's an innocence you would have
never thought he made fifty seven cat
seventeen years old but he did so study
the content follow the content comment
on the bottom and if you got some
questions you can always snap you the
snap tab should be right here baby
nineteen I will generally respond to
getting thousands of messages now so if
I don't get back to you
and once you get back to you so with
that being said we get our new pillow
here Paul that was not the best throw
but we'll forgive you yes yeah and it's
football season then why would you throw
it like the way they shot free throws
back in the day hey if you got questions
comment on the bottom if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click on the
subscribe button here and notification
to be the first to be notified every
time new videos come up our goal is to
get 2 million subs by the end of the
year we need your help to help us get to
a million subs by the end of 2017 with
that being said thanks so much for
watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]